votre avis quelle est la série française
préférée de ces trente dernières années
est écrit c'est un gars là et c'est pour
ça que j'aime cette émission qui arrive
en troisième position après de série
game of thrones et la casa des papes n
est un gars une fille c'est la série de
concepts préféré des français juste
après on retrouve camelot capitaine
marleau qui arrive en 9e position
julie lescaut 14e et après il ya le
bureau des légendes l'engrenage donc on
s'est fait on s'est dit on va se faire
un petit top 3 des sketches d'un gagne c
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
classement
gilles moi pas du tout moi j'aurais mis
le service après vente des émissions
mais ce n'est pas une série serrée ça
faisait partie d'un bien bossé c'est ma
première intervention dans l'émission
ouais c'est certainement la dernière
c'était moi c'est pas mal ben oui kelly
moi je suis d'accord avec ce choix parce
qu'un gars une fille ça quand même été
un des premiers à faire des passes ti
comme ça de sketches entre un homme et
une femme et je pense que les gens se
sont reconnus dans cette série là ça a
marqué c'est ça je me suis quand même
étonné de le voir après tant d'années
encore dans un cas c'est ça mon dieu
parce que moi je trouve que ça a
beaucoup dit malgré tout dans
l'esthétique dans la même dans la
manière d'écrire et tout ça moi je
trouve que c'est quand même un peu
démodé et serait alors on va voir
regarder en numéro 3 on a chaud d'un
sketch dans la salle de bain c'était ça
a fait émerger bien sûr jean dujardin et
alexandra lamy et jean dujardin et
alexandra lamy qui sont venus serait que
jean dujardin il avait fait plein de
choses avant il fait partie d'une bande
qui s'appelle amiens car les blues où il
a fait des nous c nous un arrêt après la
bande du galon et c'est vrai que dans le
métier tout le monde disait tu m'en
rappelle jean dujardin est exceptionnel
mais c'est vrai que ça ça sert comme on
dit dans le métier sa brique et panaris
n'est pas bon il n'arrivait pas à faire
la différence alors que dans le milieu
tout le monde disait que c'était un
acteur exceptionnel qui était très drôle
et c'est ça qu'il a fait émerger
regarder ce petit ski à l'intec
[Applaudissements]
mulhouse ça y est on est prêt et les
bandas mobile et où il voudrait bien qu
une fois les propos tom attend un bain
110 bowdam espèce de bateaux vise le
bateau vas-y woody mêlée parra est
visible tous les matins je peux pas
prendre de gants sont souvent potable là
géré à lui je la connais tellement verra
d'imagnier elle me regarde en disant tu
as vu j'avais raison c'est ça oui
c'était étonnant parce que c'était fait
pour les trentenaires horizon pas
accroché du tout tout de suite ceux qui
ont accroché c'est les petits enfants
que ça a amusé de voir ce qui allait
arriver plus tard et les grands-parents
qui s'est rangé des voitures et qui
regarde ça avec les petits enfants alice
trentenaires sont venus bien après tu
connaissais safran guillemot je regarde
comme un an je n'avais pas ce que ça
passe c'est vrai que c'est sur youtube
que vous montrez la première rencontre
entre chouchou et loulou regarder mais
tu as tu envie un jour et mangez pas
avoir un bébé
tu veux garder la liberté dans un couple
très indépendant dans un groupe un bébé
c'est la femme du couple
alors s'il ya pas de bébé à fait de la
mère de famille qui voit passer des bons
moments et les restos
h au foot on
foot ouais j'ai bien géré ou toi j'adore
faire l'amour aussi tu m'excuses de
scientifiques oui
[Musique]
non
sans larmes axa
ça pue ça
nick la casse toi alors j'en aurai
remonter un petit peu mais c'est quand
même sympa c'est un peu à l'époque on
pensait que c'était un boulet de faire
de la télé et les dons étaient quand
même propulsé dans le sillage du cinéma
devenir des stars tous les deux grâce à
la télé